hello everyone welcome to this video my
name is junoja i'm a phd student at
stanford university today i'm going to
tell you about budget smooth analysis of
the module maximization and the related
problems
this has joined the work with my advisor
avid rubinstein
let me use a motivating application to
explain to you what is modular
maximization
suppose we are trying to get our friends
to vote but we are so busy so we only
have time to remind care of our friends
to vote
so we select care of our friends and
remind them to vote
and then they'll remind their friends to
vote
and their friends
and so
this application can be captured by a
problem called influence diffusion
the objective of this problem
is modeled as a monotonous modular
function
for this specific application monotone
means more of your friends you remind
more people will vote in the end
the module means the same person cannot
vote twice even if two of their friends
remind them
besides application in social science
the module function is often used to
model evaluation function in economics
and scan theory
moreover it has a lot of applications in
machine learning like sensor placement
in the future selection
now let me formally define what is the
monotonous modular function
suppose we are given a set of elements v
which is called ground set
and we have a function f
that maps from any subset of v to a
non-negative real value
and we let f of i conditional s denote
the marginal value of element i to the
subset s
a function is modular if it satisfies a
diminishing return property
namely
for any subsets s and t where s is a
subset of t
the marginal value of i
to s is at least
the marginal value of i to t
and the function is monotone
if for any subsets s and a t whereas a
subset of t
the value of
s is at most the value of t
the objective of the modular
maximization is to choose
the optimal subset of k elements in
order to maximize
f sometimes the cardinality constraint k
is also called a budget
this problem is solved decades ago
specifically there is a greedy algorithm
that achieves 1 minus 1 over e
approximation of the optimal value
basically the gradient algorithm starts
from an empty solution x
and it runs in k iterations in each
iteration selects the element
that has the largest marginal value to
the current solution and add
the element to the current solution
it turns out
greedy algorithm is also optimal because
there is a matching hardness result that
says it is impossible to beat one method
over e using efficient algorithm
more recent research focuses on
designing streaming parallel robust
or faster algorithms that get 1 minus 1
over e of the optimal value
so what about the missing one over e the
point is 1 minus 1 over e is really just
a worst case guarantee
in practice people observe greedy does
much better
how much better the answer probably
depends a lot on application or instance
there's a recent paper that shows greedy
achieves 80 to 99 approximation for many
realistic instances
a nice open problem in this area is
white really achieves better performance
in practice what makes practical
instances
easier and is there an even better
algorithm than greedy in practice
there are many previous work that try to
answer these questions by modeling
beyond worst case modular functions
for example magnetic curvature measures
how close a module function is to an
additive function
coverage and undirected graphs these are
special cases of some modular functions
stability assumes if you perturb this
module function by a little the optimal
solution doesn't change much
random perturbation is basically adding
some noise to some modular functions
finally we have a more recent notion
called sharpness
however these proposals they suffer from
two kinds of issues
either they're just too strong
assumption and intractable to verify in
practice
or there simply can't beat one minus one
of three approximation
so in summary we have a lot of great
ideas
but we really don't understand what is a
nice modular function
therefore we are faced with beyond the
worst case diagram
on the one hand we want performance
we want to account for the missing one
over e or at least a fraction of it
on the other hand we want robustness
we want our model to apply widely to
practical instances
and we want the modeling assumption to
be easy to verify in practice
our approach to resolves dilemma is
starting from an overlooked object
recall that the modular maximization
problem has two objects
as modular function f and the budget
constraint k
instead of modeling beyond worst case
modular functions we can also model
beyond the worst case behavior of the
much simpler object the budget
this approach is motivated by both
practice and theory
and we will show we can get both
performance and the robustness
in practice many applications of some
manual maximization have many users with
the same objective function for
different budgets
for example in influence maximization
multiple advertisers try to maximize
their influence
in the same social network
therefore optimize essentially the same
as the modular function
however their budgets can easily differ
by an order of magnitude because of
different business sites
in another example of feature selection
machine learning engineers try to select
features for the same machine learning
model in the same data set
therefore maximize essentially the same
approximately submodular function
however the number of features they
would like to select
could easily range from 100 to 1 million
because of different computational
resources they have
finally
in practice verifying beyond worst case
assumptions for budgets
is much more tractable than for
functions
because we just need to calculate the
empirical distribution of the budgets
in theory all the existing hard
instances break under significant
observation of budget
specifically given a hard instance
namely as a modular function f and the
budget k
consider the following new instance
where this module function is still f
but the budget is changed to either 10
times k or k divided by 10.
for the new instance even outputting a
random solution would achieve 95
approximation
therefore we revisit some modular
maximization by considering average case
behavior of the budget
specifically we are interested in the
following questions
first
what's the optimal algorithm given
distribution of budgets
is grid is still optimal
second
does average case behavior of the budget
allows optimal algorithm to achieve
better than 1 minus 1 over e
approximation
in expectation
if not
can we prove a stronger hardness result
that is robust to any budget
distribution
to formally answer these questions we
introduce a framework
called budget smooth analysis
the name is inspired by the celebrated
smooth analysis by experiment in the
turn
admittedly
the analogy is not perfect
because we need a significant provision
of the budget
now let me introduce our model budget
smooth analysis
first we fix the budget distribution
for example the budget distribution of
2020 democrats candidates campaign
then the university picks a single worst
case modular function f
arguably all the candidates are
optimizing roughly the same function but
have very different budgets
for example they could use their budgets
to maximize the influence over the same
social network
which i have explained earlier
then we sample a random budget from the
distribution
finally we run the algorithm on the
instance given by f and k
our analysis shows in this model
grid guarantees that average candidates
campaign was 67
optimal
let's do this one more time but a bit
more formally
first we fix the budget distribution d
and then adversary fix a single worst
case modular function f
after that we sample random budget k
from the distribution d
and run the algorithm on the instance
given by f and k
the performance measure of the algorithm
is the expectation of the approximation
ratio
the expectation is taken over the
randomness of the budget distribution
for this model our analysis shows that
greedy guarantees average case candidate
campaign was 67 percent optimal
so this implies that
most candidates are doing better than
one man's one over e just by simple
markov argument
recall our desired rata
our model makes no assumption on
function and the noisy model is arguably
very simple so it can be widely applied
to many different applications
and can also be verified very easily in
practice
how about performance
we explain the four percent out of
missing 37
and our model requires larger
perturbations
this is good but not enough by itself
there is room for future work
for example one can combine the budget
smooth analysis with a model that makes
assumptions on functions to get even
better approximation ratio
we are ready to state our main results
first we prove that
in the budget smooth analysis model the
greedy algorithm gives optimal
approximation factor in expectation for
every budget distribution
as a result extends to map reduce and
parallel algorithms that are also greedy
type algorithms
by optimal we mean optimal among
efficient algorithms
namely polynomial time algorithm
assuming p is not equal to mp
or the algorithm that uses
sub-exponential number of curves in the
value oracle model
we find this result quite surprising
because
greedy algorithm is independent of the
budget
in other words greedy intrinsically
adjusts itself
to the budget distribution in the
optimal way
second we derive a simple but non-convex
problem that computes the optimal
approximation ratio in the budget smooth
analysis model for any budget
distribution
we observe better than one minus one rb
approximation by solving this problem
for many realistic budget distributions
finally we prove a robust hardness
result
that says no budget distribution
allows better than 90 approximation
because of the time limit i will not
show you the proof of any of these
results
but if you are interested you can read
the paper or send me an email
instead
i will show you the numeric simulation
for the second result
our numerical simulation computes
optimal approximation factors for
various budget distributions
by solving a non-convex program
on the left column you can see different
budget distributions we tried
there are some synthetic distributions
like uniform distribution log scale
uniform distributions
and there are also some real-world data
sets
like the top 10 ad campaign on facebook
ads
and the 2020 democratic
candidate campaigns
on the right column you can see the
worst case approximation ratios here
worst case stands for worst case module
function
and you can see non-negligible
improvement over the baseline one minus
one over e for all these distributions
in hindsight budget smooth analysis
alone is probably insufficient to
explain all the missing 37 percent
that said there's still some room to
improve
in comparison even the original north
most analysis showed a huge polynomial
runtime for the simplex algorithm but
now it is significantly improved
moreover here is why i believe
budget smooth analysis is important and
should be applied to other budget
constraint problems
budget smooth analysis provides
attractable beyond the worst case
performance test for the worst case
optimal algorithms of budget constraint
optimization problems
it helps us identify the right optimal
algorithm
by tractable i mean
the noise model of budget smooth
analysis
is reasonably simple
it allows us
to analytically solve for the best
algorithm
also
in practice we can easily
verify our assumption of budget
distribution
by calculating the empirical
distribution
let me give you a few examples
for the modular maximization we showed
that the worst case optimal greedy
algorithm is also optimal in the budget
smooth analysis model
so it passed the performance test
now i give you a negative example
so this is another recent project in
this direction
where we study procurement auction in
the large markets
so basically this is knapsack problem
so we have a buyer and a bunch of
sellers who have values and costs
the only difference is that in this
problem the costs are private
and therefore
we need to design a truthful auction for
the buyer
to give incentives to the sellers
and make them report the true costs
for procrimal auction problem
coincidentally the worst case optimal
choose for auction also has 1-1 over e
approximation
we prove that this auction is stuck at
1.1 over e for any budgeted distribution
it is not budget's most optimal so it
failed the performance test
instead we devised a new auction that is
budget's most optimal
and it passed the performance test
it beats 1-1 over e in expectation for
any non-trivial budget
by non-trivial i mean there has to be at
least two budgets in the support of the
distribution
that's not the end of the story
we further show that our new auction is
instantly optimal compared with a large
and natural class of auctions including
the previous or optimal auction
and empirically we saw that our auction
out performance
previous optimal auction by a large
margin
on realistic markets somebody from many
natural distributions
this slide shows the simulation results
of procurement auction on synthetic
markets
on the left column we have seller's
distribution of costs
so we use gaussian distribution uniform
distribution exponential distribution
and gaussian mixtures
on the right column we have the
approximation ratios of the previous
optimal auction and our auction
we can see that
the approximation ratio of previous
optimal auction is very close to 1-1
over e
for all the distributions
and our auction is able to outperform
the previous optimal auction by a large
margin
so the takeaway is if you designed a
worst case optimal algorithm for budget
constraint optimization problem
budget smooth analysis should
immediately be your next test
if your algorithm is budget's most
optimal this provides rigorous evidence
that your algorithm is probably also
good beyond the worst case
if not there might be better worst case
optimal algorithms that have better
performance in practice
and the budget smooth analysis could
serve as a heuristic that guides you
towards such algorithms
namely during your quest for the
budget's most optimal algorithm you
could find better worst case optimal
algorithm that performs better in
practice
this is exactly how we found the better
procurement auction
that's all i want to say
thanks for watching